(energetic music)
- [Voiceover] When you're
looking out from the platform,
usually it's just water everywhere,
which makes you feel really, really tiny
jumping into this giant ocean.
I'm Rachelle Simpson, and I'm
a world champion cliff diver.
It's very similar to Olympic diving.
The only difference is that the end
we're going to land on our feet.
As I climb up on the platform,
you hear the wind blowing in your ears.
Sometimes there's sea gulls
zooming around my head.
To hear the announcer call my name
it's kind of like I'm
falling into this hallway
and the sound's slowing cutting out,
because that's when I'm going into focus.
That's when I set my feet
and then my arms go up.
I count to three and go.
Your body's on autopilot
and your brain is just
sitting back watching.
Front somersault, full-twist,
a second somersault, pike
position, a half-twist.
(splashing)
When you hit the water at
first you don't notice anything
and then it starts all coming back.
You create bubbles underneath the surface
and you feel those bubbles
pushing you back up
to the surface, quite a
cool feeling, actually.
Then, you come up, take a breath of air,
and the rush of adrenaline, it's
like you've been
holding it off and not
even breathing until you
hit that water.
Each time I enter the water
it's another successful moment
of convincing my brain to
do something I'm scared of.
Each time I get a sense of
empowerment when I overcome it.
I love it.
(splashing)
(audience cheering)
(successful music)